will walden worked as boris johnson's
press secretary and kathryn macleod was
a special adviser to the former
chancellor alistair darling uh uh will
catherine i won't talk to you about
larry the cat we can move on from that
but i do want to ask you about uh the in
trade that is facing the next person to
be in number 10. and will of course she
worked with boris johnson i mean how
much do you think lizzy's this trust if
it is her is going to
govern in a boris johnson mould
uh yeah morning kamali i i think
probably quite a lot um and i think that
the difficulty there is that she's gonna
have to reach across the tory party to
united at an incredibly difficult time
um you know no prime minister has faced
an entry like this quite like this i
think i think in in recent times and
she's got her work cut out and all
indications are that she's going to go
very much in the kind of
johnson mold now if she doesn't fill her
cabinet by reaching out across the
conservative party with a breadth of
talent you know she may come unstuck
pretty pretty quickly
she's got a massive task ahead of her
and i think that uh you know very much
the jury is out she spent the last six
weeks appealing to a very narrow base
and that is the conservative party
membership she's now got to appeal to
the country she's got to come out
swinging and running hit the ground very
hard in terms of what she's going to to
offer the country and part of the
problem is that they've spent six weeks
sort of dancing around this issue around
the cost of living crisis so even
yesterday she wouldn't answer the
question and i think look the campaign
has gone on far too long and people need
answers she's going to have to deliver
them you know within a matter of hours
yeah we'll find out i guess in a matter
of hours perhaps uh the direction that
she's going to take and kathleen let me
just bring you in on this as well
because of course uh as an advice as to
darling um when he was helping save the
country through the last huge economic
shock we had after 2008 i mean the kind
of work that needs to be put in place
early to make sure that whatever does
happen is effective is really important
it's very important and i'm sure that
when there's trust or if it is in detail
that is prime minister will be presented
with options whenever she goes into
number 10 because the civil servants
will have been working on it throughout
the campaign
i don't know what will means by liz
trust's governing in the boris johnson
world but goodness me if she was going
to learn any lessons it would be to
absolutely not govern in the boris
johnson mode well because his own
colleagues in the conservative party in
parliament threw him out but she is
going to face a very very tough time
which we will know tomorrow i think
we'll get an indication
immediately before her cabinet or a
wedding's to another what she's going to
do she's changed her mind quite rightly
during the campaign she's realized the
events events dear boy are as pertinent
now as they ever were and instead of
just only talking about tax cuts as your
correspondent said she's now going to
have to face up to how the country is
going to deal with the crisis which is
probably pretty comparable to the
financial crisis we faced in 2008. she
is facing a very difficult time
yeah and will i let you answer yourself
but i imagine when you say
um governing that boris johnson you're
talking about boosterism you know
sunlight uplands saying that
everything's going to be all right if we
just get through this period
yeah there is an element of that with
with liz trust and and clearly you know
catherine's right i don't think she's
going to repeat the the mistakes that
boris made which were you know pretty
self-inflicted and they were about the
fact that he liked to run a a loose ship
and you know he wanted he wanted to be
loved by everybody and and you know he
wasn't a details guy i think it's quite
clear that she is a details person but
you know she has advantages that he does
not have on the other hand i think she
has disadvantages she you know she
doesn't have the charm she doesn't have
the the charisma she certainly doesn't
yet have the political reach in terms of
of the electorate so the jury is out
there but uh i think uh you know
the the proof of of of liz trust as
prime minister will be about how quickly
she can take those options that
catherine uh mentioned
and deliver something that that is
concrete for people that will make a an
immediate difference
in in their lives and the key thing she
she's advocating around that whatever
the issue in terms of money that's
provided for energy bills is that our
energy mix has been caught up you know
intrinsically with you know gas supplied
to europe and us buying that gas we need
a different energy mix and she's she's
rightly tackling that and saying that
she's going to hit the ground running in
that regard to change the energy mix in
the in the years ahead because the these
crises in the future will not go ahead
it will continue to to hurt if we don't
change that energy mix
and catherine obviously when you were
in government advising allies to darling
it was a very different kind of setup
the way that number 10 was run i mean do
you expect to see liz trust perhaps
going back to some of those uh
pre boris johnson ideas of the way that
number 10 is running the way that
operation is carried out didn't serve
him very well did it
well i mean i don't know what liz trust
is thinking really between from which i
read from people who perhaps do know
what she's thinking is that she intends
to reduce the size of number 10 bringing
a different
style in the in number 10 which is
probably quite right i think liz
chance's big problem is going to be
have the people that who have been
supporting it they're very right-wing
they do
i think they'll be probably a bit
dismayed already that she's talking
about helping the country and not just
talking about tax cuts and as one
very senior tori said to me she's going
to perhaps have to pay a very high price
to the supporters who threw the weight
in behind her aim at the very beginning
i think who is in her cabinet will be
very um
will be very illustrative of the kind of
government that she's going to run and
from what i hear and i was not know
boris johnson fan that he was much more
receptive to ideas than she might be
because she is surrounded by very
hard-line conservative members of
parliament
we'll pick up on that then i mean
is that going to be perhaps liz truss's
biggest hindrance the people that she
had supporting her through this
leadership contest and then the people
that she may well appoint to cabinet
means catherine says this is the biggest
crisis that the government has faced
since 2008.
yeah
and i i think i you know alluded that to
that at the beginning you know if she is
going to
first survive in office and then fight a
general election uh i i think that she
has to reach out across the
the breadth of talent in the in the
conservative party and that may mean
appointing you know a number of
high-profile rishi sunac supporters i
don't think sunak is going to serve in
her cabinet uh you know i think he's
made that that pretty clear but but if
she doesn't do that then the the sort of
you know
internal machinations of the tory party
may well tear her apart before she has a
chance to show us what she is is made of
so it's a huge choice in terms of those
people and i think you know who knows
whether the predictions that we read in
the newspapers are correct if they are
she's clearly i think saying no i'm not
going to do that i'm going to go with
the people that i know and that i trust
and those are the people that are going
to deliver for me and i i think that
that that she may well find that quickly
it comes up short in that regard yeah
and before we let you both go i want to
get a thought from you will uh and give
you final thought catherine on boris
johnson i mean um what do we expect he
is going to be like if uh when he
returns to the back benches he's
pointedly not ruled out the fact that he
might well try and run for leadership
again in time to come so will you know
the man i mean what's he going to be
like as a back venture yeah
kamali that's not going to happen i'm
pretty sure of that i think it suits him
to be able to float the idea that he's
still around i think this is a really
bittersweet moment and it's pretty
bitter rather than sweet for for boris
johnson much of the last year this stuff
has has been at his door if he looks in
his soul he'll he'll realize that it's
you know he's contributed in the main to
his own downfall but he doesn't want to
say that because that trash is the
legacy and the legacy is fundamentally
about big headlines it's about ukraine
it's about the vaccine rollout it's
about the 80 seat majority it's about
getting brexit done he will be seen as
one of the most consequential prime
ministers of the last 50 years i've no
doubt about that but consequential isn't
necessarily successful and i think that
what will happen is that boris may well
prove a bit of a thorn in the side of
the of the new leader uh you know and
the tory party for the next 18 months i
don't expect that he'll stand in 2024
and i think he'll go off and make a lot
of money as a columnist and an
author you know in years to come
thank you for that will and catherine
final thought to you then do you agree
with with much of that do you think that
boris johnson will have it within
himself to sit quietly on the back
benches
i think that will be hard i think will
is right though but he'll be sitting in
the back benches causing mischievous
writing interesting columns to make
people laugh doesn't matter whether
they're actually correct or not he's an
entertainer and perhaps that's at the
end of the day was what will be what he
is remembered by
okay catherine mcleod former special
adviser to addison darling and will
walden uh special adviser to boris
johnson previously thank you both this
morning we're going to find out in a
couple hours time who's going to be the
person replacing boris johnson in number
10. thank you for this morning